دعنا ننتقل إلى الجانب الطبي من
هذا ، فهناك متغير ينتشر في
الهند ،
ما الذي نعرفه عن هذا البديل ، ما مدى
قلقنا في الولايات المتحدة
حيال ذلك جيدًا ، فنحن لا نعرف الكثير
عن المتغير الذي لا نعرفه
يعرفون الكثير عن تأثير هذا
المتغير لأنه لا يوجد الكثير من
التسلسل الجيني الذي نتحدث
عنه ، لذلك نحن نعلم أن الناس يصابون
بالفيروس لكنهم لا يعرفون
نوع الفيروس المحدد الذي
يسبب مرضهم لأنهم "  إعادة
التسلسل غير الكافي
ما نعرفه عن هذا المتغير هو
أنه
نوع منه شوهد في جنوب
إفريقيا ، وقد شوهد نوع منه في كاليفورنيا ،
لذا فهو
لا ينزل إلى الهند فحسب ، بل إنه
قد انتشر بالفعل في جميع أنحاء العالم وهو
الآن  تم التقاطها في أماكن مختلفة
، أصبح من الواضح بشكل متزايد
من دكتور فوشي وغيره أن
اللقاحات التي نتحدث عنها
تبدو أنها وقائية ضد هذا
البديل سواء كنت هنا في
الولايات المتحدة تحصل على لقاح  أو في
أي مكان آخر ، من
الواضح أن المشكلة هي أنه لا يوجد عدد
كافٍ من الناس لديهم هذا النوع من المناعة ،
لكنني الآن أنضم إليك من
مستشفى البكالوريوس في تناقض حاد للغاية مع
ما رأيته للتو في شوارع دلهي ،
هذه مؤسسة عالمية متطورة
حوالي 500  أسرة وقد تم
هدمها تمامًا اليوم فقط فقدوا ثمانية
أشخاص بسبب نقص الأكسجين في
غضون بضع ساعات وانضم
إليّ
مدير المستشفى الدكتور scl gupta
الطبيب كيف تتعامل وكيف كان الأمر على
الأرض  يحدث هذا ،
إنه أسوأ موقف
اليوم
بسبب نقص الأكسجين ، فأنت تفقد
حوالي 12
مريضًا ، ويتزايد العدد
الذي تراه كل يوم في
الصباح وفجأة ترى أنه لم
يعد الشخص الذي كان من الممكن أن تنقذه
[موسيقى
] الشخص الذي كان من الممكن أن
تعالجه وفجأة بسبب عدم وجود أكسجين
يموت شخص ما ، هذا
لا يهضم على الإطلاق وغير قابل للهضم وقد
فقدت أيضًا زميلًا لك اليوم نعم في
نفس الوقت  الوقت اليوم
أحد كبار المسؤولين في
مستشفاي rk himtani وهو رئيس
قسم أمراض الجهاز الهضمي
فقدنا مثل هذا الشخص الرائع والذي
كان محاربًا حقيقيًا للكورونا
خلال العام الماضي بشكل مستمر وهو
يقاتل من أجل
كورونا لقد أصيب بالكورونا لقد كان  اعترف في وحدة العناية المركزة ، كان
أحد زملائي يقول إنني
كنت أتحدث
معه وأمامي انهار
وتوفي جميع هؤلاء المرضى
اليوم في غضون ساعات قليلة
أفهم
ذلك لأنه كان عليك حتى إصدار
نداء من أجل الأكسجين  ولم
يحدث هذا ما
يحدث لآخر مرة بشكل مستمر
ومنتظم ،
فنحن لا نحصل على الإمداد الكافي
من الأكسجين في هذا المستشفى الذي
أعمل فيه وليس مستشفاي فقط في معظم
المستشفيات الكبيرة في دلهي التي لا يتم
إمدادها بشكل كافٍ  بواسطة أوكسي ،
ما يربطه مستشفى من الحكومة اليومية
، يريدون
رهبانًا بوذيين للأكسجين في سريلانكا يطلبون
المساعدة الإلهية
لوقف موجة قاتلة من فيروس كورونا
التي
تجتاح الهند.  يرغب الرهبان والبوذيون
في هذا البلد
في مشاركة تعاطفنا
مع شعب
الهند تصارع الهند أسوأ
تفشي لكوفيد 19 في العالم
مع أرقام قياسية من الإصابات
والوفيات وانتشرت
الأزمة عبر الحدود إلى نيبال
حيث تقع العاصمة  الآن في
ظل إغلاق لمدة أسبوعين ، يقول المسؤولون
إن معدل الإصابات هناك
قد زاد خارج سيطرة
الأنظمة الصحية في العديد من المناطق
التي يقع معظمها بالقرب من حدود
الهند قبل أن تصبح القيود
سارية المفعول ، حيث
اكتظ الناس بمحطات الحافلات للخروج من
هناك مخاوف من فيروس كورونا في المدينة ، وقد نموت بسبب
فيروس كورونا إذا بقينا هنا
لذلك سنعود إلى قرانا في
سريلانكا ، حيث تم إغلاق أكثر من 100 منطقة في جميع أنحاء
البلاد
بسبب قفزة في الإصابات في مدارس أبريل
وأرباب العمل مغلقون  طُلب من الفلبين الحد
من عدد الأشخاص الذين يقدمون تقارير إلى
العمل ، مما يمدد
إغلاقها في العديد من المدن حتى منتصف مايو
الأسبوع الماضي  تجاوزت الدولة
مليون حالة مؤكدة مما أدى إلى زيادة
موارد المستشفيات خاصة
في عاصمة البلاد
حيث تفشي المرض في أسوأ حالاته ،
وليس لدينا أسرة كافية ، وجميعها
ممتلئة بالفعل ، تقوم
تايلاند بتحويل محطة تسجيل
الوصول في مطارها الرئيسي
إلى تطعيم
مركز المطار به مساحة كبيرة ،
وقد تمكن الفريق من التباعد الاجتماعي الجيد ،
وأغلقت بانكوك مؤخرًا المتنزهات العامة
، وصالات الألعاب الرياضية ومراكز الرعاية النهارية حتى
التاسع من مايو
، وفرضت غرامات تصل إلى 640
دولارًا لعدم ارتداء قناع في باكستان العامة ،
مما أدى إلى خفض 80 في المائة من
الرحلات الدولية القادمة في
الأسابيع القليلة المقبلة
في محاولة للحد من عدد الحالات
هناك ،
يتدخل الجيش أيضًا للقيام بدوريات في الشوارع
في مدن مثل لاهور
لفرض ارتداء الأقنعة والتأكد من
إغلاق المتاجر في الساعة 6 مساءً.
احتواء انتشار
الفيروس
لكنه قد لا يكون كافيا لبعض الأماكن التي
أعلنت سنغافورة أنها تشدد
قيود دخولها  إغلاق
حدودها للزوار من بنغلاديش ،
نيبال
، باكستان ، وسري لانكا كريستي لو ستاوت
CNN
هونغ كونغ